a giddy Nancy Pelosi pretends to be
somber while signing the official
impeachment resolution against President
Trump and simultaneously doling out
souvenir pens to her jackal colleagues
meanwhile admir Putin moves to
consolidate power and yet another blow
to democracy in Russia we will examine
how and why democracy fails then
President Trump wins big in the trade
war with China and even left-wing
outlets have to admit that his strategy
specifically his tariffs worked while we
all celebrate the economic and
geopolitical victory we will take a look
at the more important win the overthrow
of conventional wisdom then CNN releases
the audio from the post debate war in
Boerne exchange at Tuesday's Democratic
primary debate because CNN is still
trying to make Elizabeth Warren happen
stop trying to make Elizabeth Warren
happen Elizabeth Warren is not going to
happen
finally the mailbag all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
all right she's impeaching him I had
there have been like seven different
moments where this is the official
impeachment Pelosi announced months ago
she said we're starting the official
impeachment inquiry then they do the
inquiry then they take the official
impeachment vote but it wasn't totally
official because she wouldn't deliver
the articles of impeachment to the
Senate then she signed the official
impeachment resolution and then her
seven house managers delivered the
official impeachment resolution and the
fiction that they're all living under
right now is that this is a very somber
serious day for America these House
Democrats they don't want to impeach the
president they just have to because of
that thing he did and we can't get too
specific about it because you know it's
very complicated but he did something he
the orange man was bad and so we have to
impeach him but we don't want to accept
their giddy about it and they're eager
to do it and they were ready to do it
before they even figured out a tenuous
reason to impeach him the impeachment
managers include Representative Hakeem
Jeffries from New York Val Demings from
Florida Jason crow from Wisconsin Sylvia
Garcia from Texas and Zoe Lofgren from
California and then of course the to the
to impeachment stars Adam Schiff and
Jerry Nadler
those are the people now it's it's worth
pointing out of the impeachment managers
of the seven impeachment managers six of
them supported impeachment before the
Ukraine whistleblower complaint so
they're all saying that they don't want
to impeach the president but this matter
on Ukraine that none of us can really
describe because it's completely murky
and a hoax and BS nevertheless this this
incident with Ukraine is the reason that
they have to impeach Trump except six of
the seven impeachment managers supported
impeachment publicly before the
whistleblower complaint before anybody
knew anything about this Ukraine phone
call so it's completely disingenuous
it's insincere the most
interesting person here of all of the
impeachment managers is Zoe Lofgren the
reason she's most interesting is Zoe
Lofgren has been involved in three
different impeachment processes
it's pretty amazing she's involved
obviously in this one she's an
impeachment manager on Trump she was in
the house since 1995 so she voted on the
impeachment of Bill Clinton and she was
actually working on the staff of
representative Don Edwards in the 1970s
when they when Edwards and she helping
him were preparing the articles of
impeachment against Richard Nixon
Lofgren shows the problem here the the
increasing problem with impeachment and
with our democracy or our representative
democracy or our Republic we'll get to
the difference in a little bit she shows
the problem we're impeaching too much
we're impeaching too frequently this is
not what the framers and the founders of
our country had in mind we shouldn't
just be throwing out the president every
time there's a new Congress in charge
and they don't like the guy Democrats
are pretending to be upset about the
whole thing they love it and that is a
big danger to our republic we'll get to
that in just one second first I got to
thank our friends at Robin Hood
because you know we just got an
excellent trade deal signed today that's
actually the big news of the day we'll
get to that wonderful trade deal and
what it means for all of our bottom
lines but you got to think about your
personal bottom line 2020 is the perfect
time to start thinking about 2040 and
with Robin Hood you can invest in stocks
options and ETFs right from your phone
you can even spend and earn interest on
uninvested cash I know I look I never
took any sort of financial literacy
courses I don't know anything about the
financial services industry Robin Hood
makes it easy they make it easy to get
started and learn as you grow with an
intuitive app experience and no
Commission fees on trades none zip nada
stock prices don't have to hold you back
you can buy a piece of a company that
you love for as low as one dollar and
build your portfolio a little bit at a
time by
one share by half a share by three and a
quarter shares by whatever you want it's
up to you it's up to your budget it's up
to your goals your first stock is on the
house thanks to Robin Hood when you set
up a free account go to Noel's dot Robin
Hood com to learn more and claim your
free stock annual percentage yield on
uninvested cash is paid by program banks
and is variable Robin Hood Financial is
not a bank the free stock offer is
subject to terms and conditions all
investments involve risk other fees may
apply visit our B&H d dot CEO slash
feeds all right so they're giddy to do
it they're so happy to deliver the
impeachment resolution Nancy Pelosi was
so happy to sign it as Nancy Pelosi is
signing this impeachment resolutions so
excited President Trump was signing the
trade deal with China because after two
years of a trade war with China we were
told we're gonna lose this is terrible
the American people are getting killed
in this and what a dumb strategy it
actually worked we got a very favorable
trade deal so the Democrats the best
they can do is throw out the president
who's doing a good job and the president
is delivering I mean it what an amazing
two weeks for Trump not every two weeks
of his presidency has been like this
okay there have been a few moments that
I've not been so thrilled about some
policy moves that I haven't been so
happy with but the last two weeks oh my
gosh he that first of all we get
attacked by Iran twice kills the Iran
kills an American contractor and hits
our Baghdad embassy very perilous
situation I mean we're being attacked by
a hostile foreign power Trump takes out
their top guy Trump takes out the
number-two guy he we now have heightened
tensions with Iran they back down so we
establish deterrence major geopolitical
win and then on the heels of that we
finally inked the trade deal which is
beyond all of the Foreign Affairs issues
the single most important issue right
now facing the United States abroad more
important than Iran more important than
North Korea more important than anything
in the Middle East China China is the
adversary China is the threat so threat
to our economy it's a threat to our
national security and finally after
many years of nothing we've got a deal
on this it's really great news we'll get
to that in a second but first I just
have to show you the hypocrisy of the
Democrats well Trump is actually helping
out our economy helping out our national
security all they can do is try to throw
him out and they're happy to do it
so Pelosi a little while ago was giving
an interview about impeachment and she
said it's a somber serious difficult
terrible sad day for America when they
have to impeach him here she is this is
a very sad time for our country
there's no joy in this it's sad there
must be some burr we must be prayerful
there's no joy in this there's no joy in
this Nancy then why are you smiling
grinning ear-to-ear well you sign the
resolution you can see if you saw the
clip yesterday she's she's signing this
impeachment resolution and who's got all
of the Democratic colleagues around her
oh and there she just looks up she's so
happy she's never felt this way before
yes she swears it's true and she owes it
all to those Democrats how happy she is
she gave away
commemorative pens when presidents sign
important pieces of legislation the
Affordable Care Act right Obamacare or
made major pieces of legislation like
that they will sign their name only a
little bit at a time a little part of
one letter and then another letter and
then another letter because they want to
switch the Pens because they want to be
able to give out those souvenir pens to
people to help remember this joyous
occasion and it's a great piece of
political swag in Washington Nancy
Pelosi is doing that for impeachment
she's giving at an actual celebratory
souvenir for this somber serious sad day
they're thrilled why shouldn't they be
thrilled for radical Democrats
impeachment is a huge win and I mean
Democrats with a capital D and I mean
Democrats with a lowercase D both both
kinds of Democrats the Democrats of the
party and the people who support pure
radical democracy both
be thrilled with impeaching the
president if you're a purist Democrat
with a lowercase D you should hate you
should hate this particular president
you might hate the president in general
but you should hate this one in
particular he was elected without the
popular vote right so right right away
that's a problem and generally speaking
people who were pure lowercase D
Democrats who want more power to the
people hate the executive branch and
often hate a lot of our Constitution you
know if you're a purist Democrat if you
really believe that 50% plus one should
decide how we're governed you should
despise the Constitution because the
Constitution limits the rights or it
limits the power of the people to define
our rights I know that's a little
confusing right because it gives rights
to the people it acknowledges rights
that the people have but it also limits
the people's power to change those
rights willy-nilly if if half the
population plus one decides to do it I
mean look at our gun rights for instance
Democrats are so upset generally
speaking the left liberals so upset that
if the majority of liberals in any given
area want to take away our gun rights
they can't do it because they're reined
in by the Constitution how about the
judiciary the judiciary is very
undemocratic unfortunately you'll often
have bad judges try to legislate from
the bench but as it is set up the
judiciary is there to put a hold on the
will of the people to put a hold on
democracy to restrain the desires of
democracy and not let them do whatever
they want how about the executive the
executive is not beholden to the will of
the people like the legislature is
executive gets elected every four years
and it's elected through this mechanism
of the electoral college so the votes
are weighted a little bit differently
and smaller states have just as much of
a say as larger states when it comes to
part of the Electoral College Road but
not the whole calculation it's a very
complicated process set up by our
founders and framers unlike the
legislature which is up for election
every to you
and is the expression of the will of the
people it is the expression of democracy
the nearest that we've got to it in our
government what the founding fathers
knew is that too much democracy can be a
terrible thing we see that here we see
that in Russia we'll get to that in a
second because Vladimir Putin just
dissolved his government but before we
get to that I've got to thank our
friends over at Rock Auto I like Rock
Auto because the quality of the products
is unmatched it's super easy to navigate
and I don't know anything about cars so
that's important for me it's always fair
prices but the thing I really like about
them is they're a family business family
business serving Auto Parts customers
online for 20 years go to Rock Auto comm
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they just have
a legacy all right they've got a family
legacy they got a great reputation
they've been doing this for as long as
anybody on the internet and they always
do a great job they've earned that
reputation for a reason they've got
engine control module brake brake parts
tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether that's for your classic or your
daily driver you get everything you need
in a few easy clicks delivered directly
to your door when you go to the auto
parts store the brick and mortar you go
there they never have your part right
they just go there and then they go
online and they order the part and they
mark it up a lot and you pay a lot more
money you don't need to do that
the rockauto.com catalogs very easy to
use very easy to navigate you'll save
money you'll always get a fair price
head on over there you can choose your
vehicle you can choose your brand
specifications prices you prefer always
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com go there
right now to see all the available parts
for your car or truck and then right
Knolls came to wles in me how did you
hear about us box that's most important
so that they know that we sent you
rockauto.com all right or founding
fathers knew that too much democracy is
a terrible thing we have a great
republic another another term for a
republic you could say is a
representative democracy it's not a pure
democracy many cases it's not
than SuperDuper democratic it's a
representative democracy a republic
what's the difference we have
representatives in place that express
our desires we don't do it directly well
what's another difference we have
constitutional limitations on our
democracy if the majority of the people
if ninety-nine percent of the people if
a hundred percent of the people want to
ban guns from America they can't do it
because we have a Constitution if a
hundred percent of the people in this
country want to ban free speech or want
to establish a national church or want
to eliminate freedom of the press they
can't do it because we do not have this
pure democracy because if we did have
that pure democracy it would be much
much worse much worse form of government
than the republic that we have the
current threat to our representative
democracy is not too little democracy
it's too much democracy we have been
hacking away at our constitutional
safeguards for over a century now we
started it well we started a long long
time ago but 1913 direct election of
senators takes away the right of the
states to elect the senators takes away
some of the delicate balance of our
federal government of our constitutional
system then in 1942 you get the Supreme
Court decision Wickard V filburn
dramatically increases the regulatory
power of the federal government reduces
the power of the states reduces that
balance of power
another example that was just in the
news the War Powers Resolution in 1973
unconstitutional power grab by the
Congress to take the constitutional
power away from the executive what
you're seeing is the power moving from
state and local up to the federal
government and within the federal
government you're seeing power coming
into the legislature constant power
grabs and now that is culminating in
this impeachment which has no legal
basis no constitutional basis it is
simply a power grab from the legislature
against the executive it is an attempt
at congressional supremacy it's the idea
that the president serves at the
pleasure of the Congress and if the
Congress if there's an election and the
Congress becomes democratic then the
Republican presidents getting impeached
and I guess the threat is vice versa if
a Republican Congress gets elected then
the Democrat president is going to be
impeached this is a that's a system
similar to the United Kingdom the UK is
this parliamentary system so it's just
whatever party wins they control the
whole government it's very European it's
very unstable it's not not befitting of
free American people conservatives have
a different idea than that conservatives
idea is that we know there are costs to
overthrowing our legal and political
tradition like this the the tradition
that we've inherited from the founding
fathers threat all of the history of our
country it's not a simple system it's
not totally clear you can't write it
down on a little little napkin right
it's complex it involves institutions
like the electoral college which few
people seem to be able to understand or
articulate it involves this balance of
power between the local state and
federal and the the judiciary and the
executive and the legislature it's very
complicated
we realize that there are costs to
overthrowing all that and having a
simple democracy or us or simply saying
the legislature gets to pick the
president simply saying the majority
rules
when you when you overthrow that
tradition you were overthrowing a more
important democracy than the democracy
everybody talks about Chesterton
explains this very well he said
tradition means giving votes to the most
obscure of all classes our ancestors it
is the democracy of the dead tradition
refuses to submit to the small and
arrogant oligarchy of those who merely
happen to be walking about it's a great
way to think about the tradition it's
the democracy of the dead you and I are
here walking on this earth for a little
blip of time we're the arrogant old
of people who want to overthrow
everything but what a power grab that
would be what a tyranny to deprive our
ancestors once we're gone of that great
tradition what a tyranny would be to
disenfranchise
the people who come after us and the
people who have come before us for in
order for a country to be stable to
thrive to flourish you need to have that
sort of continuity and maybe you have to
respect the wisdom of the ages because
very likely your feeble powers of
intellect are not enough to recreate the
whole country from scratch
lots of people in in the West right now
are paying attention to another
democracy falling apart compare compare
what's happening in the u.s. to what's
happening in Russia Vladimir Putin right
now is amending the Russian Constitution
and it's overthrowing his entire
government so the Prime Minister the
putative Prime Minister Dmitry Medvedev
and his entire cabinet resigned
yesterday I say the putative Prime
Minister cuz when you think Prime
Minister you think somebody has a lot of
power
nobody has power and Russia other than
Vladimir Putin and Putin was the
president then he was briefly the Prime
Minister and he was the president again
and he switched roles with Medvedev but
Putin's been in charge for a very long
time this move is a way for Putin to
consolidate power
all right Medvedev has been Prime
Minister since 2012 before that he was
president 2008 to 2012 but it was really
just a trick of the Russian Constitution
so the Putin could stay in power with
that violating Constitution now Putin
wants to install some technocratic have
a power base as Prime Minister and amend
the Constitution to give himself more
power when he retires as president lots
of people in the West are upset about it
because it's another blow to Russian
democracy what my response to that is
what Russian democracy when has Russia
ever had a democracy or a republic or a
representative government never
never have they had a functioning
democracy there was a brief period after
the fall of the Berlin Wall in during
the 1990s when there was this guy Boris
Yeltsin okay Boris Yeltsin was the
nearest thing that Russia has had to a
democracy or a representative government
and he was a drunk crook who left office
with a 2 percent approval rating there's
a story that he was visiting in
Washington one time he somehow snuck out
of the White House and he was found
carousing drunkenly on the streets of
Washington alright didn't work out very
well other than that what yet you have
now Putin who is the autocrat in Russia
he just keeps himself in power a little
blip of Boris Yeltsin and you had the
communists communist dictators and then
you had the czars
at no point have you had a functioning
representative government
all right Russia has always governed at
the whims czars and one reason that we
pride ourselves in the West I'm being
better than Russia is because we have
this superior system of government and
yet increasingly we are governing on the
whims of czars to a tyranny of one is no
worse than a tyranny of many its tyranny
all the same we will get to how we can
fix that then we'll get to the excellent
Trump China deal and most importantly
the Bernie Warren moment at the end of
that debate when they were very intense
well CNN has leaked the audio because
CNN is in the tank for Elizabeth Warren
we'll get to what it means first I got
to thank our friends over at ring rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
now you probably already know about
their smart video doorbells and cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere how do you know that because
I've told you about it ring helps you
stay connected to your home anywhere in
the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you'll
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone you
know I've told you before about my
friends who I gave I gave them ring as a
housewarming gift and they thought there
was some guy kind of sneaking around
their house at night they look on their
ring and they realized it was a possum
well I have an update for you they they
heard someone sneaking around the house
again a few weeks ago and they were very
nervous they hadn't really heard this
sound before so they look on their ring
it was two possums mating so
they got an answer on that they felt
safe and they saw the miracle of life
happening albeit in a possum that was
thanks to the HD video and they have
two-way audio features on these ring
devices so you can talk to people see
hear and speak to them a solicitor right
now you have a special offer on a ring
starter yet with video doorbell and
motion activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home go to ring comm slash Knolls
that is ring.com slash knowles canada w
le s a tyranny of one is no better than
a tyranny of a million or two million or
300 million they're both tyranny our
founders set up a superior system that
you can't boil down to slogans or bumper
stickers democracy freedom you can you
actually can't do that it's much more
complicated we don't need to destroy our
representative democracy we don't need
to be in a situation where the Congress
is just throwing presidents out
willy-nilly what we need to do is
respect our traditions our norms our
Constitution and perhaps most
importantly of all our fellow countrymen
if we don't do that we are headed for a
disaster but before we get to disaster
in the meantime we got some great great
news yesterday that the mainstream media
don't want to report on Donald Trump
just won a major victory in the trade
war with China two year trade war with
China and 20 years of hostilities with
China
ever since we let China into the World
Trade Organization they've been ripping
us off stealing our intellectual
property putting spyware in our software
that they manufacture taking our jobs
illegally subsidizing steel and aluminum
devaluing their currency I mean they've
been cheating left and right and this
strategy seems to have worked when Trump
said I'm gonna Institute tariffs we're
getting into a trade war baby everybody
actually with the exception of Chuck
Schumer and Chuck Schumer's defense
Schumer was supportive of a tough
strategy with China as he had been for
20 years but it was pretty much Trump
against the world Trump against the
Democrats Trump against the libertarian
types Trump against the the never Trump
Republicans a lot of squishy people in
his own party
he said I'm putting on tariffs they all
said it'll never work
China will back down guess what the
tariffs worked US and China signed a
trade deal this will lead to a sharp
increase in the sales of us goods and
services to China and they got to do it
fast within the next year China has to
purchase an additional nearly two
hundred billion dollars worth of goods a
two hundred million dollars worth of
goods and services and and provide
strong new protections for trade secrets
and intellectual property this is an
eight part agreement there will now
pause the trade war major major deal now
it does leave in place u.s. tariffs on
about 370 billion dollars of Chinese
goods or about three quarters of the
Chinese imports into the United States
so it's billion with a B sorry it was
confused in my now it's billion with a B
here is Jim Cramer who is on CNBC so not
exactly a right-wing network this
left-wing network Jim Cramer comes out
and he says what we're all thinking and
what none of the experts knew Trump's
tariff strategy worked
manoosh ins appearance this morning did
bring us something new and that was the
notion of phase two a phase 2 B phase 2
C so story's evolving rapidly look I
think that the takeaway for me is the
tariffs worked if you go back in time
people just said listen tariffs won't
work won't change them
the Chinese are all powerful tariffs
will hurt our consumer the consumers
going to see a lot of the inflation both
at the producer light level and the
consumer level ultimately which is gonna
hurt the US economy none of that
happened the whole narrative is is that
China caved and China's can continue to
cave because we didn't take the terrace
off so I keep wondering when people
gonna recognize that it is historic that
tariffs did succeed they weren't
supposed to work the Chinese opposed to
be able to get around it didn't happen
the Chinese were kind of accepting that
they had to do something in order to
keep the American market absolutely
right this is
my favorite thing about the the trade
deal not even that it's good for our
economy it's good for our geopolitical
standing not even that it's 20 years in
the making
not even that the guy in my political
party was right and everyone else
including people in my political party
were completely wrong that that's not
even my favorite part of it my favorite
part of this trade deal is that it
overthrows stale conventional wisdom
every 30 40 years or so you get this
kind of ossified stale conventional
wisdom you know politics because
politics comes from ideas and then
you've got to distill it and enact it
and communicate it to people this leads
to talking points and bumper stickers
and slogans and then people repeat these
bumper stickers and slogans so often
that they start to believe that that is
the totality of of politics so one of
these being tariffs don't work if you
asked five years ago everybody
you pulled a hundred percent of
Americans do tariffs work left right and
center 99 percent of them would have
told you
tariffs don't work tariffs never work
tariffs are a bad idea beep-boop
beep-boop none of these people have an
education and economics none of these
people know particularly much about
global history or economic history and
yet they would have said that because we
just had decided as a political people
tariffs are always bad there's never a
use for tariffs then Trump comes in
there he goes yeah I don't sorry I
didn't go to all your fancy lunches at
those think tanks and I haven't been
politically programmed on the same level
as all you guys for the last 50 years so
I think tariffs are gonna work and we're
gonna slap a ton of tariffs on China and
then they're gonna get on their knees
and then we're gonna get a good trade
deal they said it'll never work it can't
work because our slogans told us it
wouldn't because our narrow ideology and
our conventional wisdom told us it
wouldn't yeah well it did so reality as
always contradicted the narrow ideology
same thing on trade deficits we were
told trade deficits don't matter they
that's not a big deal
well if trade deficits don't matter why
do other countries work to reduce their
trade deficits trade deficits seemed to
seem like they would matter right
a trade deficit it's how much you sell
to another country versus how much that
country sells to you there's got to be
some effect of that right if if China is
buying X amount of money X amount of
product from our country and then they
suddenly buy double that amount of
product I think that's gonna help us
isn't it
if we get to sell more of our product to
this huge market in China white why do
we even want to get into these markets
in the first place if it doesn't matter
of course it matters and Trump just
knocked over this conventional wisdom
it's very important in politics to get
out of slogans you know from from Nancy
Pelosi's signing the the impeachment
resolution to Donald Trump signing the
trade deal you can see the kind of
ossified cold conventional wisdom and
you can see opening up your mind to the
possibilities of politics what do I mean
by that Nancy Pelosi has one guiding
star in politics right now and that is
orange band bad they're not the
Democrats are really not considering the
danger to the country of pursuing this
path of impeachment but they're just
doing it because that's all they know
orange man bad orange man bad what if
orange man isn't so bad what if the
American people have the right to pick
their own president what if the Congress
doesn't have the right to overthrow a
presidential election just because they
want to what if there are constitutional
safeguards what if there is a legal
basis for impeachment
what if tariffs work what all these
things that the left is not considering
right now if we get down this narrow
path and we try to oversimplify and
oversimplify our government we're headed
for disaster if we appreciate the
tradition that we have if we respect the
norms that we maybe can't rationally
articulate but we know they've served us
well for a long time maybe that will
help us and if we crack out of this
stale conventional wisdom that crops up
every couple decades I think we'll have
a much better chance looking at the
whole body of our American political
inheritance before we get to the mailbag
today I've just got to get to this
wonderful wonderful Bernie and Elizabeth
Warren clip from the debate so you saw
they were kind of angry they weren't
shaking hands at the end of the debate
CNN because they had their lavalier
microphone
just leaked the audio of that exchange
here it is let's not do it right now you
want to have that discussion we'll have
that discussion you call me land you
told me all right let's nothing I don't
get it I just want to say hi yeah good
okay
what an amazing exchange the best part
of it being Tom Steyer who is just like
that kid like when you're staying over
at your friend's house and your toupee
and the two parents start fighting with
each other and you're just in the
kitchen like trying to get a glass of
water that's what Tom Steyer was hey hey
I just wanted to say hi Bernie seems
like a pretty nice guy and he wears that
nice tart and tie Tom Styer he's also
the richest guy on that stage by far so
you'd think Bernie would say like hey
Tom please give me a donation later but
it's very charming moment at the end the
meat of that exchange though of course
is at the beginning elizabeth warren
comes over she's i think you called me a
liar on TV Bernie said what are you what
you you called me a liar right you we
had a weird describing different things
that happened we're describing one event
and you're saying this happened and I'm
saying not this happened so you called
me a liar too but let's not do this here
Elizabeth why would you want to do this
on stage with our microphones on you
could have done it during the debate to
you it doesn't make sense until you
realize that Elizabeth Warren is a liar
and CNN is in the tank for her this is
obviously a setup
why would CNN release this audio if it
weren't a setup for Warren the weight
the way you can tell who is telling the
truth here is that one Elizabeth Warren
leaked it right before the debate and
they and she leaked it to CNN because
CNN was hosting the debate and then at
the very end she approaches Bernie she
didn't get her good hit in during the
debate itself she didn't get a good clip
from that so she walks up and very very
awkwardly sets him up to have to respond
doesn't sound natural she walks up very
awkwardly and says
what's what is my script say uh you I
think you called me a liar on TV huh
what do you say now what are you gonna
say now Bernie and he's so caught
off-guard by this you called me a liar
why are we doing this year
see you later Liz I have to give it to
Bernie on this occasion I think he's the
one telling the truth and I think she's
a liar
why do I think that she is one of the
most notorious liars in the country and
if she's not lying let's say that let's
give her the benefit of the doubt let's
say that this meeting took place two
years ago and Bernie said I don't think
a woman could win in 2020 which I don't
believe for a second but let's say that
happened still we have to believe
burning here because Elizabeth Warren is
the boy who cried wolf Elizabeth Warren
said she was in Native American Indian
for her entire career for professional
benefit complete lie she just recently
said that her child went to public
school went to a private school rather
that was a lie she said that she was
fired from her teaching job because she
was pregnant that was a lie she
contradicted it herself she lies all the
time all the time and yet Bernie Sanders
when you think of all of the false
statements he's made in his career and
there are many of them all the crazy
ideology is spattered in his career
there's a lot of it you can't find too
many lies he doesn't live very much and
there's video of Bernie decades ago
saying he thinks a woman could be
President you got to give it to Liz
Warren even if this if in this actual
event Bernie Sanders was the what
actually did say what she said he said
you gotta give the liar award to
Elizabeth Warren it's just that's
that that's the only rational judgment
you can make and the CNN set up here
it's total stab-in-the-back set up is
classic you know last go-around 2016 CNN
gave the gave the debate questions to
Hillary Clinton when she was debating
Bernie Sanders they did that because the
corporate media hates Bernie Sanders
I don't like Bernie Sanders either but
we have different reasons for it but the
corporate media certainly hates him they
try to pick Elizabeth Warren they're now
calling her a snake in the grass and I
have to say that the Democratic base
left Whig base the calls are a snake in
the grass is clearly pretty right all
right let's get to the mailbag first I
got to set about a Facebook and YouTube
head on over to Daily wire.com you get
me you get the under Clavin show if
you're not a subscriber you're missing
out you get the Ben Shapiro show I mean
right now using promo code null Skinner
wles you get 10% off any plan that you
choose that's my gift to you head over
to Daley wire.com slash subscribe
pick the plan that's right for you for
as little as ten bucks a month members
get our articles ad free access to all
of our live broadcasts at show library
three hours of the ben shapiro show
bonus content access to the mailbag and
more and then our all access to your
gets you into exclusive live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben drew NAT ton of
daily wire writers and special guests
and don't forget you will also get the
leftist here's tumblr you will get all
of that plus 10% off when you use promo
code Knowles stop depriving yourself
join in on the fun go to daily wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
all right we've got the mailbag so let's
get right into it
I always run late so we've got to hurry
up from Sam hi Michael I've worked at a
summer camp for the past five years
today I got my contract for the upcoming
summer and they've given me a demotion
and a pay cut I feel like I should start
looking for jobs at other camps but the
reason I wanted to run a camp in the
first place was for these kids I've been
working with the same group of kids
since they were eight and now they're 14
am i abandoning the principles that made
me want to go into the camping industry
if I take a job at another camp thanks
for all you do know you should you
should get another job I mean it's great
to support the kids it's great to love
what you do it's great to to enjoy the
work that you're doing but you can't be
disrespected like that if you're really
taking a pay cut if you're really being
demoted that's showing a disrespect from
your employers now maybe it was your
fault you owe and let's entertain that
possibility let's say you weren't doing
your job that well so you know they they
bumped you down a little bit okay maybe
that means you got to work a little bit
better at your get a little better at
your job figure out how you can thrive
in that role I guess you could do that
at your current camp or you could do it
somewhere else or in the other situation
maybe they just don't they're not
showing your respect as an employee and
you've got to move on that's the way
life works they're great jobs but
sometimes you just got to move on
and you'll find another group of kids
and you'll be stronger in your
profession from Grant
hello Michael I recently took your
advice and parted ways with my
ex-girlfriend of five years who didn't
want kids in the future she blocked me
after I deleted her pictures from my
social media I miss her dearly and I
don't know how to get over it
you mentioned reading Ovid's remedy for
love and I simply cannot comprehend it
any advice on how to read of it and/or
get over my ex thank you for all you do
and for your consistent spreading of the
word of Christ
well I'm sorry you know you're going
through this difficult situation I do
remember your question grant from last
time which was if I'm remembering
correctly it was that you and your
girlfriend had broken up but you kept
seeing each other and she was kind of
stringing you along but she said that
you guys have to take some time off and
she didn't know if she wanted to you
know have kids or kind of live the life
you want to live and my advice last time
was don't let your ex-girlfriend string
you along never do that never ever do
that it won't it won't help you win her
back and it will degrade you so if you
still really like her a lot
I guess there's a chance you could get
back together that happens but it's not
gonna happen if you keep seeing your
ex-girlfriend all the time and hanging
around and saying you're my best friend
and I love you so much
hey no work it's true that Ovid is a
little tough for the modern audience and
yeah I don't know you know it's even
more difficult because it's translated
from Latin and okay how can you how can
you take Ovid's advice for getting over
an ex girlfriend well you're already
doing it Ovid has a lot of advice he
says stop seeing her don't see her
destroy all her pictures that's another
piece of advice
he says destroy all her portraits and
you're deleting her facebook pictures
okay that's about the same thing another
bit of advice that Ovid a pagan gives is
to sleep around with a lot of women
right away now you're a Christian so you
probably don't want to do that but you
could start going on dates you could
start pursuing other romantic
relationships and you should do that
immediately you must move on if you're
really gonna break up you don't want to
be in that middle ground either be
together and get married and have a life
together or completely break up and move
on and by the way if you do completely
breakup and move on a year or two years
from now you might end up getting back
together because she's gonna realize she
made a huge mistake and come running
back to you but what what is not gonna
work is if you were in this middle
ground where you're kind of hanging
around the same place please love me
love me that is that is not going to
help anybody it's not gonna help you
when your girlfriend back it's not going
to help you move on you should operate
from the position that this relationship
is over it's not gonna work no knock on
her you just want different things in
life and you are going to move on and
then see what happens from there
best of luck my friend from Ian
I'm Michel since the Democrats are
pushing for taxpayer-funded abortions
over reproductive rights should
Republicans push taxpayer-funded
firearms for second Amendment rights yes
yeah I mean not seriously I don't want
the government involved in in giving me
guns because I don't trust the
government to do that and I don't want
to expand the government in that way but
it's the same argument I mean they say
we have a right to abortion so the
taxpayers have to pay for it we have a
right to condoms so the taxpayers have
to pay for it first of all you don't
have a right to either of those things
but second of all even if you did there
is a difference between positive rights
which require somebody else's effort and
labor and money in the government to pay
for it and negative rights which is
freedom from interference freedom from
you punching me freedom from you taking
my life freedom from you infringing on
my property when our government was set
up and we talk about rights our founding
fathers had a particularly negative view
of rights freedom from and so a great a
great way to highlight that hypocrisy
for for the left would be to say okay
great you're right you you have a right
to birth control or abortion you're
right we should the government should
provide that but I have an actual
constitutional right to a gun so give me
my ar-15 baby see what they say to that
from Deb do you think salami man
sulemani will replace Che Guevara as the
Liberals new poster boy for decades to
come
honestly maybe I mean it I I know it
seems insane that you could get this
Islamic terrorist you know killed
thousands of civilians to be a poster
boy and have him on t-shirts for the
left they did it to Che Guevara Che
Guevara was a wasn't an Islamic
terrorist I guess he was a Latino
terrorists but he killed a ton of
civilians he was responsible for untold
human misery he was a total sociopath
and they put him on their shirts the
left particularly the intellectual left
has always loved violence they love
violence they prep they usually don't
fight themselves but they love the idea
of
violence you see this in all of the
despotisms of the 20th century supported
by top intellectuals jean-paul Sartre
Berthold Brecht all the way back to the
Enlightenment these guys support
violence and so I wouldn't be surprised
if the left does it - it's totally
perverse and the key is the left doesn't
know the history of Che Guevara and they
don't know anything about sulla body
they're already crying over his death so
I wouldn't be surprised if they threw
him on a t-shirt
last question Taylor Michael what are
the names of your ancestors who came
over on the Mayflower
our Christmas break my wife found out
that she has an ancestor who came over
on the Mayflower - I want to know if
your distant cousins I have for the
pilgrim was dr. Samuel fuller the other
three were what's known as strangers so
they weren't the pilgrims they were the
other guys who came over on the
Mayflower and that is Stephen Hopkins he
was a mutineer and he was actually on
the shipwreck in the Caribbean that
Shakespeare's play The Tempest is based
on Francis Eaton he was a sort of NER do
well but got along just fine and in
Plymouth and John Billington who was the
first man executed for murder in the new
world so you know we had that one good
pilgrim doctor and then a bunch of
derelicts and degenerates and they may
be the derelicts and degenerates from
from whom your wife comes as well maybe
we're cousins all right that's our show
unfortunately though by the way if your
wife and I are cousins then she's also
cousins by law with Hillary Clinton so
sorry to be the bearer of bad news
that's our show i'm michael moses the
michael knowles show have a good weekend
I'll see on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there